carried that attack and who is to blame
to all was it Daniel Haku was it shami
himself was it who who was to blame for
this we're going to come to that but
shami I just want to say something a
couple of months ago about a month and a
half ago you know yourself that I was
going to a speaker
corner just imagine the people back in
the day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the qur app now and let it testify for
you on that you read it wherever you
was brothers and sisters and dear
friends yesterday I was showing a video
and came across a video where our
brother shami was brutally um attacked
um on the first video um which you can I
don't know if you guys seen but he
claims that he was um ambushed or
attacked while he was walking in the
park then there was another video that
emerged where he was on the high road in
Shepherd's Bush that's where the attack
took place obviously I'm not going to
show you the footage um and he's been
attacked by I would say minimum two to
three people there's somebody recording
it as well now look guys we have warned
against the likes of r shmy sagid Paris
and their likes myself D hu Muhammed
hijab brother [__] many of us Brothers
we don't have anything personal I I can
speak for myself I don't have a personal
Vendetta against them I don't wish ill
on them I don't like I'll be honest
Allah subh is my witness W when I saw
that video of sh being attacked if I
even smiled because it was sad why was
it sad whose fault is it will come to
later but the fact that we see another
believer cuz Allah tells clearly in the
Quran the Believers are those that are
soft towards one another and harsh
towards the enemy of Islam so for me to
be happy seeing another believer being
attacked beaten it defeats that purpose
and not only that it falls into the
category that we criticize these
brothers often like what's the
difference between me and them if I'm
going to get happy of them being
attacked they have attacked many many
brothers
including and the one who punched AB was
actually somebody who used to attend the
classes of shi himself and Abu even
released a tweet of somebody saying but
this happened to you and he said two
wrongs don't make a right right just
because they did that to doesn't mean
now we we're like oh we want the same
done to them no we we ask Allah subhana
to rectify the Affairs Affairs and fix
their manage or their ideology which is
so distorted there is no hikma and no
wisdom which is which I'm going to come
to next so firstly and utmost I want to
make it very clear and Shi knows this
himself number one I condemn that attack
that was done to him yes and we're going
to come to the ones who carried that
attack and who is to blame to all was it
Dani was it shami himself was it who who
was to blame for this we're going to
come to that but shami I just want to
say something couple of months ago about
a month and a half ago you know yourself
that I was going to speaker corner it
was M time yes and I was walking to
outside the park where we usually prayed
with jam and I saw you and when I saw
you I came to you and I said look are
you praying M why because I don't have
anony towards you I hate what you say
for the sake of Allah I don't hate you
or think you're evil or ill intended for
that matter yes I can't question you
sincerity cuz I can't look into your
heart I came to you and I said are you
play M I saw you in crutches you had
some cres I think there was something
wrong with your leg I don't know yes and
I saw you then I said look let's play M
I don't care about my difference I put
that to aside yeah let's pray I realized
you didn't even make eye contact with me
and you just said no you know I think
you had to do woodo or something for
that matter so much so I I think I Mis
heard you I thought like you know maybe
you need a chair or something I went and
got a chair you know I said let me go
get a chair you can sit on the chair
yeah and then you repeated and said oh
that you don't have voodo for that
matter I had no problem praying with you
I had no problem assisting you I had no
problem W if he came to me and said I
need to do wo I would hold the water why
am I saying this I don't want people to
like be like oh he's just using this to
you know make himself look humble Allah
subh is my witness I don't have
animosity I have never backbitten you or
slandered you or called you names you've
done that to me but the point is what
you need to understand my dear brother
yeah you have a family I don't want to
see you hurt I don't want people kicking
you down but one thing you need to bear
in mind which I came across a recent
video is you and this FIS guy yes this
guy who can't even condemn Israel who
even said that we even boycott them
Subhan Allah you guys are casually
smoking Aki where is your hikma you know
I love Starbucks people are driving
crazy Starbucks
Starbucks I I don't drink Starbucks by
the way but you're drinking Starbucks
right I saw some of your videos you're
holding the cup I'm like man this guy's
gonna get a lot of heat now and he said
to me do you know that Starbucks is a is
a Zer supporter I said okay I said do
you know that Instagram the owner of
Instagram is a zer supp where is your
wisdom and I'm going to come to a treaty
of the treat of which connects to this
yeah you guys are laughing and joking
where is your wisdom the issue of
Palestine is a great a issue it's a big
issue it's a red line our brothers and
sisters actually we seeing children
blown into pieces man there are fathers
holding their kids in bin bags bro in in
in bags bro I like do you not think for
a second do what you say has
consequences do you think you can just
spew certain nonsense and think that
certain people who are Reckless which I
condemn what they did are going to come
and do silly stuff like this you guys
are laughing in the video of oh you know
Starbucks actually you you could have
done that video in a way because we know
there's evidence from the Quran and the
Sunnah that you don't necessarily need
to boycott that's it's true you don't
need to but to laugh I have brothers and
sisters been massacred man they're
Massac I I've got kids bro I got a
6-year-old I got a 2-year old I got two
3 month four month old man and it breaks
my heart to think that when I hold my
baby daughter that imagine she's blown
into pieces it breaks my heart you are a
father you have daughters you have kids
imagine your kids are slaughtered and
I'm and you want to boycott or whatever
and and I make a video laughing it's
going to hurt people understand that Aki
please W I'm saying this sincerely for
you understand there is a way have some
wisdom you lack great great wisdom in
your methodology and this ideology that
you
perpetrate the point is what in the
treaty ofia when the prophet s wasallam
went to do he had a dream and dream is
dream is a form of he had a dream that
they going to do Haj yeah and they went
to perform ha with all the companions
they were stopped by and then they come
and then after that was sent to
negotiate and the negotiations were what
and bear in mind he was he locked his
son up Abu jandal and he's torturing him
the mus torturing
him comes not knowing that Abu jand has
escaped and his running to was the
Companions inia and the condition is
what number one you are not going to do
Hajj do you know what kind of a big
thing that was for the companions number
two anybody that comes from Mecca to
join you as a Muslim you send them back
to us look at the Clauses they're
putting in place and the Muslims are
quite strong they could easily wage war
yes and number three anybody that leaves
your religion they can come freely to us
this is the treaty that was going to be
signed yes and just before it's going to
be signed they hear Abu jandal screaming
he saw the Believers he saw the Muslims
he saw the prophet sallam and he's like
yes finally I'm going to be saved and so
hears this they go outside and they see
it and says and the first one will take
him back is this man which is his own
son and the prophet Muhammad peace upon
him had to plead
with let us have Abu jand whatever for
that matter please let us have Abu jand
let's not we cannot send him back and
said said if you do not let me take him
back there is no
treaty the prophet wasam had to do what
signed the treaty and send abu jandal
back do you know how angry the
companions were it's an emotional state
of F and he only did because the the
another mush who came with gave the
promise that they will not harm or kill
him that's why they sent him back the
companions were so angry and I'm going
to tell you what I'm telling the story
The Companions were so angry when they
signed that treaty that when the prophet
went and told them there is no ha this
year yes none of the companions listened
to the prophet wasallam imagine a
prophet of Allah making a command shave
of your head shave of your hair and none
of them
obeyed even said things or done things
in a way where abak to tell him yes oh
this is the messenger of Allah which he
later repented for cuz because in a
moment of anger the point is what the
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alhi
wasallam the companions refused to
listen to him except he went to his tent
and his wife told the prophet wasam you
shave your hair and they will
follow the point is what the companions
are the best of beings after the prophet
these are the companions that walk the
earth they were emotional and angry when
they had to send the believer back to
the enemies who were not killed by the
way he was not killed Subhan Allah let
alone our brothers and sisters babies
man infant babies children blown into
pieces by this scum Zionist may Allah
destroy them into pieces this Zionist
government not the Jews this Zionist
fils may Allah destroy them and you are
doing it with a video with Faris
laughing joking her Starbucks a be
careful to what you say and before you
blame Daniel hu Daniel hu confronted you
on this issue nowhere did he condone the
violence
yes nowhere I heard some kind of takis
is being made call him an Israeli
Iranian agent and I think vice versa we
both know from the religion for to do so
BL that it's we are free from this yes
whoever it's been done by I don't know
I've just heard rumors yeah the point is
what people are emotional so brother
shemi in this very instance I would have
to blame no one but you yourself but
this does not mean I condone the actions
of these Reckless Brothers for coming
and attacking you yes it was wrong but
you need to understand this hypocrisy
from your side when you talk about is
hamas's fault they broke the uh the
treaty or this that Etc blah blah blah
blah blah Yi you're the same person
who's saying I got attacked unjustly
come to my Masjid and there'll be some
brothers there so when it comes to
yourself you talk about Justice you talk
about being attacked you even say that
oh you know these heers attack the lion
Etc which I don't know why why you say
that it's a form of self amazement and
why do you define yourself as a lion let
somebody else call you a lion you know
the point is this firstly that you need
to understand that what you're doing if
I go and belit a specific situation
where it is so close to people's hearts
it's such an
emotional it's such an emotional thing
and I get attacked there's going to be
Reckless people who are going to do
reckless stuff yes but you are to blame
why because you are so casually and
boldly attacking you know uh just Hamas
and not uh attacking Israel like this
Ferris guy yeah no attack people are
going to question you and put into
question everything so I blame yourself
and you and FIS for making a video you
could have done that video in a
different way without laughing you know
what I drink from Starbucks and you know
what there is an Islamic opinion that
look nobody can come and see you you
have to boycott it's from Islam guys we
need to put our hands up in Islam the
prophet was in war with the mush he was
W in the Romans he was in war with the
Jews uh the the Zion the Jews yes and he
still traded with them and sometimes he
boycotted them so the evidence is clear
the point of being attacked me you being
attacked is not cuz um you didn't
boycott them but rather you're making it
a laughing mat you're making it's like a
joke Yi how would you like it if your
children were slaughtered and I made a
video just joking yeah you so what this
guy owns a shop you know who attacked
and mass sh's kids but you know I got
buy coffee from him and I'm joking there
there should be a wisdom and hikma
behind doing it you should sincerely
condemn because people do not see the
that you have towards them and we
haven't seen this we've seen you
continuously attacking Muslims over and
over and over and over again so much so
that when it comes to the Palestinian
issue we expect you at least on this be
on Ward with us you FIS yes and certain
individuals they do not even do that and
that's why people go to levels of doing
immature prophetic City stuff like this
by attacking you Sensi on the street
which I condemn it's just it's it's not
permissible it's Haram for you to hit
another believer yes to to point a sharp
object to another believer is not
permissible let alone scaring him let
alone attacking him unless we know in
the Quran where Allah says in that if
one group of Believers goes against the
the other yes and you fight him until
they count in the command of Allah but
that is done by the ruler or whatever
for that matter so you need to
understand the way you speak your
rhetoric your speech the way you conduct
yourself even smirking all this kind of
stuff with Ferris and his fake Smiles in
that video yeah you have no shame you
have no atom we of Shame yeah have some
shame you got white beard I've told you
this four times yeah you sense this
person your brothers and sisters are
being massacred have some at least shed
a tear man even if it's fake shed a
tear anyways I don't want to long it out
I don't want to long it out nobody can
blame Dani Haku for this matter because
Dani has come to you and confronted you
on this matter intellectually he hasn't
asked for anyone to attack you yes but
you need to understand there is going to
be a group of people who are upset about
the matter for whoever it may be for
that matter okay
anybody if they saw this ATT trust
toties and saw a group a group a brother
or whatever making the matter so lightly
and laughing about the matter they will
get angry so I would advise you number
one to when you're going home walk with
individuals go with people because
you're this not going to stop yes and
we're not asking for it to happen and I
ask those to fear Allah who are planning
and plotting to attack the brother yes
fear Allah w two wrongs do not make a
right okay it does not make a right fear
Allah subhana wa tala in this matter yes
it is not permissible for you to hit
another believer okay no matter there's
no excuse in the matter refute him
academically no problem but it is not
upon you to do that so I would ask
brother shami to have security or have
people who can walk with you inshallah
because senses people are there and I
urge you to be very very careful to the
way you speak about is Palestine okay
please for the sake of Allah yes watch
how you speak the issue happened when
Isa may Allah have mercy on him passed
away and you started talking ill of him
his family members contacted me saying
they were going to come to the park to
beat you up I had to be escalate
situation by talking to isa's sister
this was supposed to happen so many
times bro you do not know what to say or
what to do you have no hikma no wisdom W
it's a lack of knowledge it shows a lack
of knowledge you look at the the prophet
said they would recite the Quran it
wouldn't go below their neck they have
no understanding is the intentions right
yes but the actions have to be according
to the Sunnah you have no hikma and I
believe genuinely you have a lack of
knowledge I don't question your
sincerity you might be sincere no
problem but you genuinely have a lack of
knowledge and you're talking about
matters stay in your lane do da to the
Christians the Jews the siks whatever
you're good at that stick to that stop
attacking the Muslims stop attacking the
Believers yes and when you talk about
sensitive issues like this have some
heart have some heart and understand
what's going on in Palestine that's all
I'm going to say nobody can blame Dan
Haku or anyone else for that matter yes
you need to understand shami that there
are consequences and be careful and we
ask Allah subhana tala to correct our
Affairs and it is sad to see this but if
you carry on like this you're going to
have sentence individuals who are going
to take the matter into their own hands
that's all I'm going to say and may
Allah subhana T protect us all and guide
us all and anything I've said wrong is
from Shan and myself and anything good
is from Allah and his
messenger